meine Damen und Herren also alles ist
bereit so zumindestens auch die eigene
Positionierung der israelischen Armee
aber es geht nicht los das ist das was
man faktisch feststellen kann die New
York Times hat daraus gemacht dass die
Gegenoffensive verschoben ist ganz
aktuell und live läuft ein Briefing da
gibt es mehrere am Tag der israelischen
Armee und wir wollen reinhören in das
was diesen in diesen Minuten gesagt wird
von dem aktuellen Sprecher Daniel hagari
ab von Libanon her und wir haben ein
getö und es gibt auch einige Probleme
wir haben
zurück mit Feuer reagiert und wir
haben dieser Stelle wo daraus geschossen
wurde
Vernet dasun wir die ganze Zeit
der IG und TR die Verantwortung wenn aus
dem Libanon geschossen wird ich möchte
ein paar Hinweise geben über den Norden
was dort passieren sollten wir haben
gesagt dass dort am Norden müssen wir
ganz vorsichtig sein und natürlich
diejenige die in der Nähe der Grenze
sind kann man dort überhaupt nicht mit
Autos fahren oder zu Fuß gehen ja das
ist alles im Norden des Landes das heißt
die gesamten Ortschaften
müssen die Leute die dort wohnen müssen
dort gerade Geschütz Räumen
bleiben und wir sehen sehr stark auch im
Norden organisiert und vorbereitet auf
alle
Überraschungen und wir machen auch jetzt
ich über gazerastreifen wir haben viele
Positionen attackiert aus denen raketten
gekommen sind und Isra Streitkräfte hat
auch heute abend stark attackiert auch
im
Gazastreifen und wir haben einen
bestimmten Kommandanten der hammas
vernichtet der zuständig war für die
gesamte Operation der Hamas der hat
alles
organisiert und der ist persönlich mit
verwickelt und er wird nicht der letzte
sein die wir töten würden in der letzten
Stunde haben wiederum eine Feuer aus den
gazerstreiben und wir werden darauf auch
eine Antwort geben also unsere Schutz
ist nicht hermetisch es ist ganz wichtig
dass im Süden müss man genauso auch
hören was hauptpartiert Hinterland
sagt um Leben zu
schützen darüber hinaus machen wir
weiter
und mit den Zielen die wir uns
vorgestellt haben zu bewältigen und vor
allem die hamasbewegung und die
hamasorganis zu
vernichten und das machen wir durch
intensive
Einsätze im gaserstreifen und auch
außerhalb gaserstreifen wir haben viele
Infrastruktur von Terror
vernichtet und dann kamen viele
Terroristen ums Leben und wir wer wir
Schwächen dadurch die Herrschaft der
gesamten Hamas in allen Ebenen
gleichzeitig tun wir etwas um uns zu
verteidigen das ist auf jeden Fall ein
Kriegsgebiet und letzten Stunde haben
wir einen Terroristen gerade in diesem
Bereich vernichtet und wir kommen an
alle die dort
sind ich möchte jetzt über den gasreifen
sprchen wir versuchen die Bevölkerung
aus der gasreifen zu
evakuieren nach Süden gehen also
hunderttaus sind schon auf der auf dem
Weg nach Süden des Streifens has
versucht natürlich diesen Prozess zum
Stoppen zu bringen weil dank weil
dadurch kann die Hamas die Bevölkerung
nicht
herrschen und die brauchen die als
Schutzschild und deswegen will die Hamas
nicht dass sie nach Süden kommen sie
versuchen also ich wende jetzt gerade
direkt an
Anwohner geh bitte alle jetzt Richtung
Süden des
Streifens und und dort gibt es
Bedingungen die euch ermöglichen werden
am Leben zu
bleiben und ich möchte über die Berichte
über die internationale
Berichte die gesagt worden ist dass die
IDF Streitkräfte bestimmten Sachen
gemacht hat
und Zivilisten mit Absicht getüt hat das
ist eine
zynische Versuch uns zu beschuldigen für
Sachen welche die Hamas gemacht
hat Hamas hat letztendlich ist noch
böser als Dach also als diestaat und
versucht sogar seine
eigene Bevölkerung zu opfern für seine
eigene Ziele und deswegen manipuliert er
mit Lügen
und falschen Geschichten und dadurch
wollen sie auch das israelische Publikum
entscheidungsträge und auch die Welt
beeinflussen ich hoffe ich erwarte
Entschuldigung dass auch in den nächsten
Stunden wird diese Mühe der Hamas
fortgesetzt werden gleichzeitig schauen
wir drum herum auf dem gesamten Nahen
Osten die Isra Streitkräfte blicken
überall und sind auf alles vorbereiten
uns bereit ist hoch und wir sind auch im
Westjordanland in Judäa und Samaria sehr
stark
präsentiert gleichzeitig führen wir ein
Gespräch mit den Siedler und den sied
Führung und sage Ihnen wie sie sich zu
verhalten haben die Armee beherrscht die
gesamte
Szene
und einmal um 24 Stunden haben wir neue
Anweisungen von Quartier
Hinterland und teilweise kann man z.B
jetzt direkt zurück in die Schule
gehen diese Anweisungen sind wichtig wir
müssen auf jeden Fall diese Anweisungen
folgen die können das Leben
retten daniel hagari war das der
Sprecher des israelischen Militärs der
Israeli defense forces in chaffenburg
erreichen wir heute morgen Professor
Thomas Jäger Politikwissenschaft
Universität Köln grüße sie erstmal Herr
Professor Jäger und schön dass Sie sich
die Zeit nehmen am Sonntag morgen für
phöniix einen schönen guten Morgen Frau
ja beginnen wir sozusagen bei der
zeitaachse Herr Professor Jäger wo
stehen wir jetzt eine Woche nach dem
hammas Terror am Beginn eines
konzentrierten Militäreinsatzes oder
doch vielleicht in der Gefahr eines
Flächenbrandes das ist eine offene Frage
und deswegen hat ja die bodenoperation
noch nicht begonnen weil eben noch nicht
entschieden ist in welcher Weise sie
durchgeführt wird inzwischen wird ja
seit einer Woche sehr massiv Gaza
bombardiert das heißt
die
Verteidigungsmaßnahmen Israels sind
schon enorm und die Frage die sich jetzt
stellt ist wie weit gehen Sie weiter in
welcher Form wird die militärische
Infrastruktur wenn die
Produktionsstätten die Waffenlager der
Hamas zerstört in welcher Weise kann das
Führungspersonal identifiziert und
eliminiert werden das ist die Frage die
jetzt bei den israelischen Streitkräften
und bei der politischen Führung auf dem
Tisch liegt und das ist eingebunden in
eine intensive Diplomat Diplomatie die
ja seit einer Woche stattfindet die
sowohl mit militärischen Mitteln geführt
wird die Flugzeugträger sind ein
diplomatisches Instrument momentan das
abstchrecken soll dass ich dieser Krieg
ausweitet aber eben auch die
intensive Reisetätigkeit von
Außenminister Blinken der in mehreren
Staaten war ebenso wie sein iranischer
Kollege die jetzt
eruieren in welcher Weise welche
Maßnahmen Israels welche Wirkungen
entfalten und das ist eine große
Gemengelage die irgendwann dadurch
aufgelöst wird dass man in der
politischen Führung Israels eine
Entscheidung treffen wird bevor wir
gleich sozusagen auf diese beiden
diplomatisch Reisenden noch einmal etwas
näher eingehen hochspannender Punkt
vielleicht noch mal eines sie haben
selber die Verschiebung der Offensive
angesprochen Professor Jäger es gibt
offensichtliche Gründe es gibt diese
Gründe die sozusagen noch einmal
öffentlich kommuniziert werden aber die
Frage ist noch was passiert im
Hintergrund gab es doch einen
verstärkten Hintergrund Druck im
Hintergrund der Amerikaner auf die
Israelis doch die Zivilbevölkerung etwas
stärker in den Blick zu
nehmen also das hat Präsident beiden
öffentlich gemacht indem er gesagt hat
äh das ist eines der wichtigen Themen
und das hängt nicht nur äh mit den
humanitären Gründen zusammen wo es auch
darum geht momentan humanitäre Hilfe aus
Ägypten zu organisieren die dort
eingetroffen ist aber noch nicht nach
Gaza kommen kann weil man sich mit
Israel noch nicht äh darüber geeinigt
hat wie diese Lieferungen überprüft
werden sodass keine Waffenlieferung äh
hier mit hineinkommen äh sondern es ist
auch die Frage wie sich dieser Konflikt
im Informationsraum entwickelt denn nach
den komplexen Terroranschlägen die die
Hamas ausgeführt hat und die für große
Empörung im Informationsraum gesorgt
haben
droht ja das ganze zu kippen in dem
Moment ind dem die Opfer in Gaza in den
Vordergrund treten und das könnte
wiederum dazu führen dass die regionale
Neuordnung die die Vereinigten Staaten
im Nahen und Mittleren Osten seit
einigen Jahren anstreben zum Stillstand
kommt und das ist et was was verhindert
werden soll deswegen ist die Reise von
Außenminister blinken heute nach
Saudi-Arabien sicher eine der
wichtigsten Stationen
weil man eben im perspektivisch und über
den Krieg hinaus denkend nach einer
politischen Lösung suchen muss und da
spielen Saudi-Arabien Israel die
Schlüsselrollen und wenn Israel über den
Auseinandersetzung im Informationsraum
politisch isoliert würde weil sich kein
arabischer Staat mehr auf enge Beziehung
mit dem Land einlassen könnte wäre das
weder im israelischen Interesse noch im
amerikanischen
ähm das ist ja durchaus eine sehr
beeindruckende Reise rout die Herr
blinkken da seit dem Donnerstag
absolviert sie haben es angesprochen
Israel da war aber auch Jordanien da war
Qatar
und jetzt eben Saudi-Arabien und gerade
Saudi-Arabien ist ja mehr oder weniger
mit der springende Punkt es gab gestern
Meldungen dass Riad möglicherweise diese
Annäherungsversuche mit Israel auf Eis
legen wird äh wie gefährlich wäre das
für die weitere Perspektive die sie ja
gerade schon beschrieben
haben ja es war so dass es eine enge
Annäherung schon gab zwischen
Saudi-Arabien und Israel die in der
Tradition steht der Abrahams Abkommen
die die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
bachrein Marokko und Sudan schon in eine
veränderte beziehungslage zu Israel
brachten aber Saudi-Arabien ist hierfür
der schlüsselstaat und es ist nicht
unbegründet an zunehmen dass der Angriff
der Hamas im der iranischen Interesse
liegt genau diese Annäherung zu
unterbinden und dass genau das das Ziel
war dass man erreichen wollte es ist war
zu erwarten und ist sehr plausibel dass
auch Saudi-Arabien in dieser Phase nun
eben dass die Annäherung nicht weiter
verfolgt wird die Frage wird sein ist
sie aufgegeben auf welche Zeit muss man
sie zurückstellen und das hängt wieder
damit z
in welcher Weise Israel jetzt auf dem
Boden agiert und wie die hisbolla sich
dazu verhält denn von da kam von Beginn
an die Drohungen dass eine
bodenoperation Israels gegen Gaza den
Kriegseintritt der hisbolla bedeuten
würde auch da wissen wir nicht ob das
eine abschreckungsmaßnahme ist ob die
wenigen Angriffe die die hebollah jetzt
täglich unternimmt einen
Ablenkungsmanöver sind ob Sie nur die
israelischen Streitkräfte binden sollen
ob sie vor Vorbereitung für etwas sind
das ist sind sehr viele Unwegbarkeiten
mit denen man hier zu tun hat und für
die politische Führung Israels ist das
eine hochkplexe und schwierige Lage
unter solch großen Unsicherheiten
entscheiden zu müssen mhm vielen Dank
für die erste Runde über das Agieren
Irans und auch des iranischen
Außenministers werden wir gleich noch
weiter sprechen zuvor nehmen wir die
Karte Diplomatie noch einmal in die Hand
danke Thomas Jäger für den Moment